got it well thank you all for being here
today to this first meeting of the
New Hampshire house election law
committee subcommittee on campaign
finance and we'll begin the meeting with
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you again for being here for the
first of our three scheduled meetings
they're each scheduled for 10 a.m on a
Tuesday the next two meetings are
scheduled for May 9th and May 16th
I anticipate that today we will
go to noon
conclude the meeting at that time
the meeting was formed at the behest of
the subcommittee was formed at the
behest of our election law committee
chairman representative
and chairman Ross Berry
and the same action I was appointed as
chairman
uh this will understand I see my role as
chairman as uh facilitating
communication among the members
to that effect
we can start out a bit informally with a
small group like this but a basic
requirement is that one person at a time
speak
if you're if you're more comfortable
with the with the protocol that people
signal with his eye to speak and the
chairman then recognizes them but you're
comfortable with that the usual
procedure
or do you think that's too formal for a
meeting of this size
okay good the discretion of the chair
excellent
alrighty so uh
I see the purpose of this meeting I'm
going to quote from a bill that was
introduced by representative Lane who's
a member of the committee but not yet
here
uh
review and make specific recommendations
on the following items
existing campaign Finance laws and any
inconsistencies that may exist therein
determining whether State campaign
Finance laws differ from current federal
campaign Finance laws
making legislative recommendations to
streamline and improve the current
process in an effort to balance
transparency and Reporting requirements
for both candidates and political
committees right
I like that last
objective particularly uh it recognizes
the need for a balance
between transparency and the burden that
reporting requirements can impose on
both the public and candidates
and with that uh we're open to
discussion I am going to facilitate as I
see my job here by asking representative
Berry if you'd like to open the
discussion with some thoughts
I'm particularly interested in
in hearing
my background's in engineering and
Science and we like to start at the top
with a concept and work down to
specifics so I'd be interested in
hearing
uh what people's thoughts are regarding
the
the ultimate purpose of campaign fine
campaign Finance system and
what basic requirements it needs to
fulfill or what a success criteria are
so with that representative bear if
you'd like to share some thoughts with
us I'd like to hear them thank you
you gotta the one on the right the one
on the left mutes everybody I found that
one out I I like to use that and
representative mirrorhead a lot right in
the middle of his speech click no
um
yes it's totally a technical error
um so I would assume that the majority
of our time will be spent on RSA 664.
correct that's the one that covers
campaign Finance laws you know and
there's there's basically four sections
in RSA 664 so there's the kind of
general terms and restrictions that's in
let's call it the opening Salvo so
that's 664 one through eleven
um and then there's duties
um that's 12 and 13A and then political
advertising
um 14 through 17A and then enforcement
18 through 23. so you know just kind of
moving forward maybe we should consider
just going through those block by block
obviously some of them will be really
quick we should probably break section
one up
into multiple pieces would be my guess
to actually look at it and you know try
we can come to consensus on because
obviously the committee does handle
campaign Finance bills and we do vote on
them
um You Know Nothing Stops anybody here
from filing anything next year but I
think maybe we can use this subcommittee
as an opportunity to find common ground
and compromise
um on the issue we won't I will tell you
right now we won't agree on everything
I'm sure but that's okay
so that that's kind of my thoughts is
just go through the
go through it section by section and
tighten it up and find ways we can agree
and maybe we just package it if we find
in the areas we agree just package it
all into one big Bill
um that we would hopefully all six of us
would sign off on and then I'm sure the
respective sides would have their own
changes that they'd make on their own
and we'll uh
okay thank you who else would like to
share their thoughts with US
proposal
um and and I think that
there are
um in a sense we I I think I can predict
where where where each party has
different priorities I think what will
really be profitable to discover is
where there's some overlap so that we
um I think often uh you know someone
introduces a bill and the other side
likes 40 of it and and the whole bill
goes down and the 40 that the two sides
overlap on is lost so if we can kind of
uh front load that I think that might be
thank you uh representative Ward you
have some thoughts you'd like to share
okay excellent we're already agreeing on
so I mean I think some things that we
could find some
um would be one and we may have slightly
different differences of exactly what
that means um but like one of the things
that is happening in the background
right now is the secretary of state is
office is overhauling the campaign
Finance online reporting system
um so I think this committee the
subcommittee is kind of formed at a
really nice time to
figure out what the secretary state's
office needs that we may need to change
to kind of help them move to that system
um and I do hold a this is my personal
opinion is I would like to see a
long-term strategy that got everyone
every single candidate pack Pao whatever
you want to call it onto the online
system
eventually making it mandatory I
wouldn't do that in two years because I
think you'd have people in the house
would Revolt but I do think a
a gradual phase-in of online mandatory
reporting would we probably agree to
something like that specifically because
I think there's things that probably
frustrate both sides right so we see Pax
or candidates will
they'll hand write these reports right
they're illegible even though it says it
has to be legible but that's in the eye
of the beholder
um they'll fax it in so then it's coming
in on you know 64-bit or whatever you
know so it's illegible to begin with and
then it comes through it's all pixelated
and
um you know also from an enforcement
standpoint of you it's hard that puts
the Attorney General's office having to
it's hard to tell if somebody's
committed a violation because you can't
aggregate the data in any meaningful way
right there's no searchable system and
you could do it you can upload these
PDFs into you know OCR readers and like
there's ways to kind of like make it a
little faster but you know I I do think
as New Hampshire's elections continue to
grow as they become more expensive and
that's an inevitable thing right so you
you have State Rep braces now that are
um
you know State Rep braces now that are
are some of them are pushing ten
thousand dollars and ten years ago that
would have been absolutely ludicrous so
I think
I think that's an area that we could
probably explore we'd need a we would
I'm I know we would need a phasing to
get the house to buy into that right if
we just said every house Canada will
report online
um but there's other games along that
that campaigns play right so they'll
hang outside the Secretary of State's
office on reporting day until 4 30 or 4
o'clock with their paper filing and then
they'll hand it to the office right
before the deadline and that way it
doesn't go up for another two days
because it takes the Secretary of
State's office time to scan it and put
it up and that's actually a even if we
couldn't agree on a mandatory phase in
of online reporting I something that I
would totally agree on is if you're
going to report in paper or PDF your
report needs to be in two days before
the online reporting system to give the
Secretary of State's office so that
they're all going online at the same
time because it's a
it's a structural
that there shouldn't be a
um structural penalty for not using for
for using the online system right like
it should be it's the only system that
we have now by the way it's relatively
easy to use it does have some quirks
um relatively easy to search
but it's
it needs to we need to be pushing people
towards it and especially these big
campaigns right I'm not I'm not overly
worried about somebody running for you
know County Commissioner who raised 750
I'm not worried about that person right
but these some of these political
advocacy Pac packs
political action committees some of
these things are pulling in a million
dollars and they're putting it up on
paper
um so anyways I think that's an area
that we could start with overlap I'd be
happy to hear if you guys think you have
you know some areas to overlap um I'm
definitely open to ideas and I don't
want to monopolize this so I'm going to
that seems persuasive I I don't see I
mean when you know in principle uh
mandatory use the online system seems
right you know you just don't want to
penalize a low resource candidate who
doesn't have
um computer savvy or maybe doesn't have
a connection at their house
um you know you don't want to make it
effectively impossible for them to
comply so you want to have some sort of
option for people to make it possible
for ordinary citizens to serve but in
um well something like that to
representative muirhead's Point you'd
put in a floor or a floor right you'd
say so anybody the first thing is is I I
really think you have to have a phase in
right so
next election every candidate for
governor every candidate for every Pac
has to go online right if you're if
you're Savvy enough to form a political
action committee in the state of New
Hampshire saving up to figure out the
online system right so let's just like
start there right and then in two years
you could tack in you know executive
Council races State Senate races right
and then in three years and three Cycles
I should say you could tack in you know
State reps and everyone else who raises
over some number a thousand dollars
right because if you're Savvy enough to
raise a thousand dollars or you're
saving up to spend a thousand dollars
yeah so you could just make it the
current threshold right
right now it's about spending not
raising so if you spend your own money
you still have to report it used to be
spend or raise but I do know it changed
right now it's just raising now six
expenditures right I thought it was both
I could be wrong I mean because if
you're I mean if you're raising it
you're spending it but
664.7
yep
yeah
by the way it's another thing to look at
is
maybe we should turn signs and you're
over a thousand yeah well how much
you're paying for signs dude Jesus
I'll give you my guy
um I mean that's another area that we
could look at is I I really do think it
should be raised or spent
um
because if somebody gives the the point
of this campaign Finance laws part of it
is to make sure that nobody's you know
getting undue influence right or who is
influencing who right so if somebody
gives you you know a hundred thousand
dollars but you don't have to report it
because you didn't spend any of it
yes my recollection that it is raised or
spent it used receipts and expenditures
I believe it used to be it may have been
changed
yeah it says um
representative Ward is correct it says
whose expenditure is exceeding a
thousand dollars
so I mean there's an easy
uh 664 seven
okay
um another thing and just I'm just
throwing this out not tangentially but
while it's on my brain um another thing
that we need to look at is
how local parties
report and what classification they are
given
um because I think there's
they kind of exist almost in a no man's
land
so your town committees your county
committees
we have an apparatus for State parties
but we need to kind of figure out
where to put these some of these local
organizations because I think right now
most of them file under packs but
that
um they're not a Pac but they should be
treated more like a party because they
are a party are they not
see what I'm saying yeah
a political Committee of a party like a
town committee yeah does not have to
register as such it runs of the umbrella
of the state party is how I would look
at it however if they again this is this
is from memory we'll have to check the
actual statute but
my recollection is that if you raise or
spend
more than a thousand then you have to
report that that's the threshold for
reporting
and naturally if you hit that threshold
I think you'd have to register as in as
an entity also
as a chairman of a local committee I
have looked at that in to make sure I
was on the right side of things and
actually had a discussion with the
secretary of state
yeah but you can see how there could be
confusion excuse me you could see how
there could be confusion oh yeah
so that's something that I think we
could
that's really in the weed sort of stuff
but it's something that does kind of
need to be addressed also by the way
it's a weight of
like do we consider that as a way around
contribution limits right so somebody
you know there's 235 towns in the state
of New Hampshire right or something
something along those lines you know if
each of them had a town committee and
each of them had a ten thousand ten
thousand ten thousand a donor could go
around and give 30k 30k 234 235 times
and then package that all up and
transfer it up and I mean it's it's not
a possible problem to solve but it's a
it's my understanding that
again I always try to draw a distinction
between what I really understand and
what I only think I understand
yeah
uh it's my understanding that as as a
candidate if you've exceeded the
threshold for reporting
you have to report all receipts
uh anything under uh
50 or under you don't have to report the
specifics but I don't think we're
concerned about 50 amounts particularly
but if you got a large donation from
a county committee or a local committee
uh once you're reporting you've got to
report it yeah once you're reporting we
have to report it so it is in the system
it's another thing I want to look at by
the way the the getting the employer
occupation and address of employer
is is onerous just so everybody knows
it's I believe that we have to do that
after 200 it's now 200. um that is
onerous
um
and it's not it's not a hide who they're
working for right but you're already
collecting their name their address
um and I think that's a very common
source of violations
um so something I'd like the committee
to look at is you end up with these
reports well they'll say you know
information requested and then they
never go back and and
find it
um
and I just I just wondered what level
it's it's necessary and we may have
disagreements on that but I just have
one to what level is that a straight
thought listening to you is that the a
G was it the AG who reported to us
earlier in in the full committee that
there were a lot of reps who are in
violation and are going to be receiving
letters or have received letters I think
it was our deputy secretary of state who
told no it wasn't you okay so then
you're right it had to be it might be
interesting for this committee to get
some information on what is causing all
these five what has caused all these
violations and for us to just talk about
which which of these common violations
um we regard as you know serious and
really errors on behalf of the
candidates and which of them we we might
think are a consequence of reporting
requirements that that aren't serving
the balance of transparency and
efficiency I I do remember the the
individuals spoke to us
indicated there were quite a few that
they had to follow up on and send
letters about yeah they sent these
letters out that said hey um you know if
you do this in the future it's a 50 a
day fine
um I I do remember a representative
sitting on one side or the other of me
in that meeting expressing concern that
laughs my goodness gracious how dare you
um it's it's
and by the way going back to the online
system and that's something that would
make their life a little easier right is
it's easier to find
um
it's easier to find violations when you
can run searches instead of having to
manually pull through reports
um I think the big one in was a lot of
people Miss deadlines
um so like like you know I I know that I
had to submit a report and I was I had
to submit six and I got to my own I do
my own last I guess uh and I you know
and I submitted it after midnight and I
was in violation because I was after
midnight you know um I know another
instance of that sort of thing happening
too it it happens I mean it's just you
know because you have it's not that you
don't have too much time it's that
it's nothing that we should look at is I
I believe is is how these reports are
spaced out right so it's like six months
six months six months
one month two weeks two weeks you know
it's just so that first
those those six months there's a lot
happens in especially in that last six
months period you actually the
the organization start taking some
serious cash and so that that probably
creates some headaches as you get this
last minute you get this six-month
report that's due and it's actually
rather large
um and I know the feds the feds do it
quarterly
um I actually don't hate how the feds Do
It
um in terms of reporting requirements
their their schedule
um
but they have you know they kind of have
some moving there's this bass drone you
know because it's different per state
for the feds they do it based on like
when the election's happening
um so but they do have quarterly
requirements and with the FEC you have
to file online I believe I don't believe
you can even file on paperwork
um the FEC system by the way is actually
like way worse to use than the New
Hampshire system just if you're filing
on your own just an FYI it's like I've
used them both and the FEC system is
like way worse we all remember there's
another reporting deadline coming up in
May right uh I believe it's due June 5th
June I thought it was I think it's May
well I'm gonna I'm gonna be checking the
exact date myself before I know the six
months I know the six month number is
coming up yeah um
I know the six months coming up uh
that's another thing that I raised with
the Secretary of State's office on their
online system is
there was this flaw this is not for this
committee to fix but there was this I
don't want to say flaw but there's this
bug where
if you tried to form you know you have a
certain I figured how long you have
after forming your committee to actually
file but basically like if you wanted to
to file the online the committee online
after the cut off but before the
reporting date you weren't able to do it
um I did raise that with the Secretary
of State's office
um so I hope they fixed that in the new
system
online system as well which I was told
it was a software problem and I don't
know that it's been fixed yet well
they're going to new system so um it's
definitely in all serious you should
raise that whatever your issue is they
seem very open to
um addressing those issues so I I would
raise it with them
um because they seemed very open to
fixing it but anyways that's not for
this committee that's that's for the
sos's office but
um
so do you have can consent can you must
elaborate on mandatory online reporting
other than me I mean I've kind of said
my kind of thought process on it which
is have a phase in and
that's where does anybody else have any
ideas or pontifications about that of
but why don't we
seek to get briefed by the Secretary of
State's office on the on the status of
any new you know system or changes and
uh and then
think about how that you know maps on to
the current requirements and whether we
might need to you know specify in the
law
um something different in order to
gently push
candidates and committees
uh into the online reporting system over
the next
so uh your suggestion is to seek a
briefing from the Secretary of State's
office on the on the current plan to
sure
I see we have a representative of the
should I submit that via email or can I
ask you now to arrange such a briefing
Mr chairman you can ask me right now and
tell me which day you would like it I
know you have a couple meetings
scheduled May 9th would be fine okay
would you say your name just for the
record oh uh I am Aaron Hennessey I am
the deputy secretary of state thank you
that was fast
um another thing that I'd like to look
at is on the political advertising side
of it I'd like to look at the disclaimer
requirements
um we have we have varying disclaimer
requirements across various mediums
media if you will and I'd like to
streamline that
um one of the most common violations
that I see is on printed materials and
or
um
candidates won't include
the address of the committee
the or the chairman and or Fiscal Agent
of the committee
and I also question kind of what
why is that necessary
in in so much as you know the
information is available online I would
never not have the paid for on there but
when you start
specifically for things
online right so they'll cancel run these
little banner ads and in order to make
that Banner ad legible the disclaimer
legible the disclaimer would actually
take up like literally two-thirds of the
advertising space
um because if you have to have all that
information on there so I'd like to find
ways to to streamline that
um another thing that that we need to
look at is political text messaging
so right now it exists in no man's land
but it doesn't under New Hampshire RSA
um the FCC considers a political a text
message a phone call
so very technically every political text
message sent in the state of New
Hampshire should end with this call has
been paid for by blah blah blah
um very technically if you if you read
it literally
um that's obviously not
feasible nor
I would say
rational but I do think there should be
disclaimer requirements as to
who is sending it
um but I think it needs to be
differentiated from a phone call which
is rather lengthy it's one thing at the
end of a phone call to say you know just
so you know this call has been paid for
by
blah blah blah for governor
um
but it's it's something that I think we
could look at
um because it does exist I mean and
there's always going to be the new thing
in
advertising that we're going to have to
go and and put under an umbrella but
that one's kind of
hung quietly and it's they're getting
more and more aggressive
there are by the way carrier
requirements for those disclosures so
the carriers do self-regulate to a
certain extent
um
pretty aggressively I might add
but something to to look at but I would
I just I would love to get rid of the
you have to put the address
of the committee on the advertisement I
would just love to do away with that
entirely I think it's
I think it's uh I I like
I I just what is the value of me putting
401 Riverdale Avenue Manchester New
Hampshire 03103 on the bottom of all my
Palm cards
is that going to change anybody's
opinion on me
so it's just something that I'd like to
throw out there of I I think there's
ways to
I think there's ways to to streamline it
that wouldn't
actually hurt transparency
right like if it says paid for by Berry
foreign h
and you go and you onto the campaign
Finance system and you type in Berry
foreign H and Berry foreign H brings up
Ross Berry 401 Riverdale Avenue
Manchester New Hampshire 603 803-3448
you know
um
in the Fiscal Agent the treasurer
what's the
do they really need the address
do they really need to know that I'm My
Own
it's
not like a it's not like a we must do
this it's just a question physical
addresses in
in in in all commercial life has
radically transformed if you go to you
know used to go to a company and you'd
know you want to know where is it
located most websites have no addresses
on them now most of them also have no
phone numbers and so what it means to be
able to you know follow someone or a
committee or an envy and locate it
locate the accountable person that's
different today than it used to be I
mean you could use a PO address a PO Box
I mean what does that what does that
tell you you know if it's
so and so campaign PO Box you know blah
blah
what did you what did you gather from
yes
yeah signature identification lack of
authorization
um but I I mean in an Ideal World in an
ideal world it would be Universal across
all mediums right that may not be
entirely feasible
but
I I I I just go back to it I feel that
there's a way to
I feel that there's a way to
make it
more uniform
without
without sacrificing the ability to know
who's
producing the advertisement correct I
have a question related to that that one
of you guys might have a more insight on
that has to do with uh political signs
say where this should be identification
on it
how would we enforce that against an
out-of-state entity I don't not I'm not
aware that New Hampshire law extends to
Massachusetts or California doesn't
extend outside the state as far as I
know well is it anything about a federal
race or uh I'm talking about I'm talking
a local state race I mean local state
races uh I would assume that we could
prosecute them because they're violating
New Hampshire law right and they're
they're somebody's doing something in
New Hampshire that is illegal right so
it's it's um I I would assume we would
be able to pull them into court and grab
them
um you know you're never you're never
going to get everybody one of the things
that always drives me nuts
and it's like maybe I'm grabbing the
third rail is where these yard signs are
allowed to be placed in public it like
really drives me up a wall
that signs go in public places I I know
I hold an unpopular opinion there but I
as somebody who works very hard to put
their yard signs in actual physical
yards it's very it's very upsetting to
me when my hard work is undone by
somebody who you know two days for the
election goes and blasts some median
somewhere
um and they never get picked up and
that's another thing that we should look
at is you know actually punishing people
for not picking up their signs
um you know if a campaign
I see both sides of the argument there
right it's like if somebody takes my
sign and puts it somewhere where I
didn't know but like ultimately like you
shouldn't been given that sign out like
if you give somebody a hundred signs you
know they ain't going in yards like
you know so this is something that it's
a personal frustration of mine that well
give you an example of a type of public
place you're talking about because the
statutes explicitly allow people to put
their signs in the public right-of-way
with the permission of the underlying
property owner so can you give me an
example
I mean they won't even get I'll give
example of uh route 101 right you can go
and blast route 101 the property owner
probably doesn't even really know where
their line is on that line uh and it's
never going to be you know it's never
get picked up and then it's you know
these signs never get picked up and then
you're looking at them and you know I
don't know it's a huge pet peeve of mine
that I hate when people don't pick them
up and I do we did have that good law
about that we that we had the good world
like people can go and pick them up from
the same party
yeah but it should almost be I mean one
of the things that we could put in here
that I would really be in support of is
after so and so date you know any sign
that's on public property after the
election is fair again for anybody to
pick up like I would love that it
actually beat me to that yeah I mean a
month after the election any sign any
sign yeah any sign on not on private
property should be
able to be picked up by anybody correct
yeah
late yeah so it's all in 664. well I
don't know if picking up the signs is
but yeah that's what I'm saying well we
got on the tangent because we started
talking about the disclaimers and then I
yeah
because we we talked about we're
basically going to look at all of 664.
yeah
yep there it is see it is directly
relevant I knew I I knew I was right not
really but I got really lucky so
well I I do think it's related to
campaign Finance because it's dealing
with a consequence of people spending
money
I did introduce this uh this meeting
representative Lane by quoting from by
quoting from uh the bill which you had
submitted
and uh quoted liberally from it in terms
of our basic objective starting with uh
exist uh
review and make specific recommendations
on the following items existing campaign
[Music]
no no apology necessary we all
understand the existence existencies of
uh
do you have some thoughts you'd like to
oh
okay thank you we talked about
um probably the only part you missed was
we talked about looking at
some sort of rollout for mandatory
online reporting
yes
um and yeah kind of
ways to ways to get people there that
won't freak people out
right I I spoke with um secretary
Scanlon actually about that and so have
hit them maybe come in and talk to us
they're coming at the next meeting
um and we did talk about a little bit
there as you know they're overhauling
the current online system and making
sure that
asking them if they need us to change
anything that would make that process
easier for them
um
slightly different topic there's been
concern over the last
four years or so about the possibility
that
LLCs can serve to obfuscate the identity
of of donors to campaigns and committees
um
yeah and and so I'm curious is there do
you think that there is overlapping
concern between members of the two
parties about what's sometimes called
the LLC loophole
um
so I'm more concerned about
the pack loophole before I would touch
the quote LLC loophole
so
um the pack loophole being if some Mega
donor wants to give five million dollars
to some federal pack
that Federal Pac can then transfer
unlimited to the state pack which can
then transfer unlimited to a state party
which is then allowed to coordinate with
the candidate
so
before we go not not to take this place
to this subcommittee to a negative place
but before we go after the llc's let's I
I would not entertain
um
I I don't want to be able to negative
this is this is truly how I feel
I do not want to entertain curtailing
New Hampshire's small businesses
while The Floodgate
the small are we doing raising
it's more of a
it's working to jump on top of each
other okay this is a work session it was
posted as such and I just want to make
and I don't think it's the small
businesses that we're going to be really
affecting it's the people who
intentionally set these up to do it to
get around the loophole I don't think
it's small businesses because those and
if those small businesses want to give
money
then they can but they're going to still
be limited by the individual limit but
which is for each race I don't remember
what we're up to but I don't think
they're mutually exclusive and I I guess
I wouldn't want to see them be treated
that way
or let's put it just in a factual you
know proposition are there loopholes
that allow entities to escape the
requirement of transparency pack
loopholes other loopholes we might
disagree about whether such and such a
thing is is a you know functions as a
loophole
but um but let maybe just introduce that
question and then do some factual
examination to see if we can agree on
certain cases Pacs or others that there
are that there are whether there are
loopholes the next question is that
there are does the cost of closing
loophole you know
exceed the benefit or and so we may or
may not agree that we should do
something about it depending on on how
elegant it is to close the loophole or
costly it is but but maybe if we could
just focus on whether there are such
loopholes that being you know
Illuminating
we should definitely put a day aside for
that
um
because we are going to have
um philosophical disagreements on there
and I don't want to
I don't
we have the opportunity to find I think
a lot of overlap and I don't want to do
that let's put that at the end after
we've found what we can't agree on I
guess is what I would say before we um
but good for us because
I'll end my my opinion on on that this
subject with this I worked in campaigns
for many moons many many moons
and I know
that
just from practicality in many different
states
that
the money always finds its way there
legally it always finds its way there
um
you can make arguments to me about it
should be 100 transparent but there's
just so many ways to get around the law
legally to get around the intention of
the law legally that and that's that's
been one of my historic oppositions to
the quote LLC loophole is I do disagree
with you I think a lot of small
businesses donate via their LLC one of
my small businesses donates with via
it's LLC
um I my issue with shutting them off
it's like my thing with them is why do
we always shut them off first when the
it's like you're you're trying to put a
trying to trying to block up the stream
while the river is running right over
there
um but that'll be I'll end it with that
but my one thing I would say is we
should do that last because we will have
those agreements I'm off for doing it
last I mean I think the you know
it's really it's really an open-minded
fact-finding spirit and not a
pre-judgment that such and such a thing
has to be shut off so there might be you
know like a question about whether
disclosure requirements are appropriate
um
for the kind of thing it is uh and and I
personally have a very open mind
um about about the whole question so I
haven't prejudged what policy is
absolutely necessary even anyway that
that would be the spirit of it I think
yes I I think it comes Under The Heading
of balancing transparency with burden on
candidates and campaigns
in general and I think a good first step
here would be actually to quantify the
magnitude of the issue how much money is
involved
I think how
we we do have information I think from
the campaign Finance systems that as it
exists I think we could derive
information on how many llc's donate
money correct
we could get a dollar amount can we I'm
not sure that well well we'll have to
find out because right now they're not
required
LLC no so you get money yeah well yeah
when so when you donate via an LLC
um you you could say you know give you
know this is from you know X LLC
um the issue is finding out going back
to the mandatory online reporting the
issue with finding out how much which
llc's are being used like this is
difficult because you have paper filings
and you can't just start like it would
be really nice to be able to search you
know give me all contributions that end
in LLC right and then it populates it up
and you could see you know are there
um are there but it's not just llc's I
mean these are not non-profits can do
that any entity any legal entity can do
this or group of people can can do this
so it's it's we'll do it I want to do at
the end because but
But to answer your question to answer
that question is we wouldn't be able to
really tell without going through every
single campaign Finance report uh every
single contribution uh and typing them
out
I mean the the data exists because the
candidates have to report receipts and
above 50 they have to report the source
of the receipt so that so the data
exists now is it how practical is it to
extract it but I I still think a good
first step
to discussing this would be to get some
data on it if it's a hundred thousand
dollar problem around what uh
consideration I'm looking to Define it
as a problem but if it's a hundred
thousand dollar
uh level of
uh event
then maybe it's not a big worry
Statewide if it's 10 million then we
might want to look at it but we need to
what I call bound the problem how big a
problem is it and what would it take to
get the data to do that I don't know
it's worth looking into
in my opinion
I want to look into it and I think we
wait till the end and we'll get the data
all right
Mr bear representative Berry I I just
turn on in case we started talking I
don't have anything okay um other than
just ideas you know
things that aren't you know well I think
this is a good a good purpose of first
meeting is to get ideas out there well I
I like to look at
um
under Section six
two
uh push pulling
is
only right now
um subject to telephone calls
and polling in general is moving towards
mixed
mixed responses so some some of it is
still conducted by live person phone
calls very few in New Hampshire is
conducted by ivr which is the robocalls
pre-recorded messages
um and a lot of it is done text
messaging online so that's something
that needs to be tightened up if we're
going to stay within the spirit of a
push-pull
I've never seen that loophole abused
before just for the record but it's
always been one of those things of like
hmm if I was doing this this is how I
would do it
um
so just something that I think we could
probably all agree on to tighten that up
and
um
yeah an easy thing to do that would be I
I've never liked the idea of like they
tell you how many calls you can do I
think it should be I think it should
like it should start off with like this
is a message test or something or this
is you know we are we are message
testing on behalf of a client you know
the following one we say is
you know opinion base or something like
that some sort of disclosure that would
just get rid of the because they have a
formula it's like if you're running for
Statewide presidential office you can
have no more than 2 000 connected phone
calls that last no more than two minutes
each
and by the way like I did have a
congressional race I worked for they
asked us we had a complaint filed
against us that we were conducting a
push-pull we weren't we had to produce
our script we had to produce our call
records so they do look into it it's not
like it doesn't happen
um but it should be uh
it it
no it's it's state for congress no well
Federal but we we control Federal yeah
which would be another interesting thing
to see is like is that even
constitutional because what's I think
it's like bass versus State of New
Hampshire or no bass versus Gardner I
think was the court case
um but they did about uh pre-recorded
phone calls I don't know I'm getting
like way into the Weeds now but that is
a disclosure issue which is under
what's
uh it's the definitions
um so definitions defines it as uh oh
yeah 17 and then I think there's an
actual section about push polling
um 16 identification of political
16a
a through D oh my goodness
um
so it's a just another thing to tighten
up I would guess
um
and you're concerned about push pulling
done by I mean most polling is sort of
uh web-based
yeah mixed delivery yeah mixed delivery
is what I would say I mean a lot of it's
web they are moving that direction
um we don't need to get into the
intricacies of polling and waiting and
non-response bias
um but it's our law I guess the the
underlying messages our laws are all
geared towards
phone calls and if we are going to stay
within the spirit of our law we would
need to adapt them towards modern
polling methods
um because you could in theory run an
online poll
that is a push pull
that would not actually meet the
disclosure requirements
um you know if I said you know
representative Muirhead is well known
that Retros in a Meerhead hates puppies
and kittens does this make you more
likely less likely and I could run that
you know 50 000 times one of the goal
guys that's a it's a message testing uh
when in reality is it's a push-pull
because it's our push-pull laws are
written around telephone calls just
saying if if it was to be violated
not that I'd be familiar with the
by the way you may get some calls from
just say heads up out there
it was not cheap
yes and I understood the context of the
remarks that they're basically no entity
or animal that representative mirrorhead
his favorite favorite animal is in fact
a skunk
um
don't ask him why but
Jesus so I think there's stuff like that
that we can tighten up
[Music]
um
and then another thing that I would like
to look at
um is when we did pass campaign Finance
reform two years ago
um
it was I know it was the intention of
this body to get rid of the pre-filing
period
um and the AG world that it still exists
so if you recall from the conversations
right the total overall contribution
limit for a candidate was seven thousand
dollars it was five thousand one and one
right and we took it and made it five
thousand and five thousand so we took it
from basically seven thousand dollars we
probably we were taking it from seven
thousand dollars to ten thousand dollars
um and we inadvertently took it from
seven thousand dollars to fifteen
thousand dollars
um so one of the things that I would
extend as an olive branch when we get to
um
that subject is putting it back in line
with what the legislators legislate
chores intent was
um
because a a doubling would have been a
uh
Ross do you remember the build number we
did that with no I believe it was this
billed as the uh Sweeney Alexander Berry
campaign financial support package so
you can probably Google that prop up
lots and lots of coverage Lots
yeah it was it was a real barn burner
um but I don't it just really upset me
that they were like no you didn't get
rid of pre-filing and I was like no we
we like explicitly got rid of it like
but probably something to fix before
and then we'd have to deal with
obviously if we kicked it into this
current cycle we'd have to deal with
um contributions that have already come
in and how to handle those to make sure
that nobody is returning money that they
it
speaking of the AG I don't know if you
guys already talked about this are you
were you gonna have somebody come in and
talk to us about or ask them about what
their most common what they see is the
most common and what they would like to
have I don't know whether Ann Edwards
would come in or there's somebody else
there I don't remember his name but
yeah we did discuss we didn't set a date
because the deputy secretary was here so
that was convenient for next week for
next time but
um we did discuss we wanted to see what
the most common violations were
um and to representative muirhead's
Point uh how how egregious are these
um which one of these could we stomach
um tweaking or doing away with and which
ones are actually like affronts to
transparency in the in the limits and
oh yeah yeah that's right chapter log of
that
so it looks like it's HP 263 from
thank you
uh
representatively in my opinion having
the aid someone from the AG's office
come in and
and discuss with us the most common
uh campaigns Finance reporting
requirements that are violated and
an idea the seriousness of each category
I think that's a good idea would you
care to contact them and invite them for
our May 16th meeting
sorry I can't hear you
say the AG
person in charge of these things used to
give us a thick report every year of all
the investigations but I haven't seen
one of those and yeah I mean and five or
six years and Edwards came in and talked
to us about orientation but I don't
do we want to scroll through the
definitions is that too tedious to see
do we actually want to like
go through it like a study group
is everything a college everything
that's this is what we do this is really
good a lawyer college professor you know
and they did give me a degree I believe
I mean
the last half the class is asleep you're
we better ramp it up then because I see
the members of the public and thank you
all for being here by the way
appear to be awake so we need to ramp
this up who doesn't who doesn't wake up
thinking God I want to talk about
detailed campaign Finance laws and
disclosures today it sounds just amazing
so try this page 218 664 13A there's a
typo we should fix that one can we all
agree on that no how dare you repot into
reports
where is that
page 218 the first page on 664 which
down to 664 13-a repots by
governor-elect yeah of course
there's all kinds of these things
uh where does it say repots
it's uh 664 13A third line under in the
table of contents oh repots yeah yeah as
we're dealing with
yeah I think they just heard HP
I I think they were hearing this one
uh I think they were hearing the
is it online do you have the RSA online
or is that just a typo in this book I
let's make sure that's not our only
accomplishment though right we could
take that and restart somewhere in real
political fashion we could take that
back and be like look at what we did
yes representative mirrorhead uh in
response to your question
you just uh passed to me which was an
interest of transparency I'm going to
read it uh would it be appropriate to
invite members of the public to offer
comments and suggestions I'm certainly
not against it in principle these
meetings are not advertised as public
hearings but
uh I'd say that's uh
we'll play that by ear that's to me
that's
to me that's uh more of a Time issue
if we if we have time
as I've said I plan on this these
meetings going from 10 to 12. I'm not
going to be rigid about it but for
planning purposes and if we have extra
uh it doesn't violate any protocol that
I'm aware of regarding work sessions
where's the typo Jerry well it's it's
we're looking at right now it's not
online
I'm sorry I brought it we're gonna get
logged out of the typo
are you looking at you're looking at
so that's on the SOS but that's not the
nobody cares okay would someone please
tell me exactly what we're looking at it
appears so on the New Hampshire gen
court site which is where the RSA is
housed online it is correct on the
Secretary of State's website it is your
thoughts it makes me feel so much better
all right
so as a typo in the printed version
Professor the election was for the
Secretary of State Side so it says
repots right here oh I see I see but on
on lot but on the website that you're on
which is where we look up the rsas it is
reports
um
they're different that's what I'm
establishing they're they're they're
different uh
I personally prefer repots but that's
I guess we can
I guess we could we just have to Define
it just have to Define repots
shut up
he was never he was never gonna talk
as chairman of this of the subcommittee
do I have the authority to stipulate
that repot as published
in this list of election laws is uh is
to be read as report can I stipulate
that you know if without objection in
the interest of moving on in the
discussion without objection
all right ready for lunch
so just want to go through definition do
you want to set we've got what our goal
is to get out of here and zip through
them just want to just want to start
with 664.1
and just yeah read it and yeah let's do
it all right
volunteers to read it
well we have a college professor here
whose idea was this
uh representative Muirhead thank you
provisions of this chapter show apply to
All State primary General and special
elections but you'll only apply to
presidential preference primaries as
provided in a section the provisions
relating to political advertising push
pulling and enforcement RSA 664 14
through 22 shall additionally apply
the presidential primary City Town
School District and Village District
collections thank God definitions as
used in this chapter
we're moving on to section two now
section two that's what you're doing
what's the difference between the
presidential preference primary and a
presidential primary
uh that's the same thing presidential
primary is the presidential preference
primary Institute strike preference so
you want to strike preference no unless
it's a legal term of artifice or
something well to be fair they would
know they actually are
um different they are actually well
they're not different in effect but they
are different in word here so
presidential in first sentence the
president preface primaries and segments
presidential primary so just want to
strike preference
a lot of inconsistencies in the whole
chapter well let's let's clean that up
then
see we did it we thought we were you
ever I thought the definitions was going
to be a joke and then
right there
sorry the applicability excuse the Liars
the applicability oh God here comes I
will tell you the definitions are often
the heart of the issue well they're
important too because they help prevent
future confusion and ambiguity which
leads to confusion
they themselves created
and create a greater potential for
conflict which is bad
generally
okay uh if that's a suitable definitions
in section two is used in this chapter
one election quotes means any general
biennial or special election
here we have political party primary
or here's presidential preferencing or
presidential preference primary oh no
has provided RSA 64-1 so we're going to
stretch scratch preference again yeah
unless again I think we might unless
there's some do some Googling different
reasons specificity of the word
preference is adding something important
we can keep it but if not we said we
were going to protect first in the
nation and here we are yeah
maybe we should maybe we should delete
preference and add first in the nation
to ever use the president okay and there
um
candidate means any person publicly
declared as such and for whom votes are
sought in an election okay let's pause
there
so
person who's publicly declared as such
and whose votes are sought in an
election
that would not include what we call a
write-in candidate
well a part right in Canada if they're
publicly declared and it's interesting
that I agree publicly to clear because
we in my town committee uh you know we
sent around an email saying suggesting
that everybody write in so and so for an
office that had no formally declared
candidate so we've it's a different
category I think it can be a write-in
campaign can't that be carried out
without you
acknowledgment by the proposed candidate
yeah I'm aware of such things happening
on the town level we did we did it
in Merrimack County for um
the attorney for the county attorney a
couple years ago
or maybe Iranian publicly is you know
filed you're filing who is filed for
their candidacy with the Secretary of
State well that doesn't happen until
June
um publicly declared but don't they have
to publicly declare if they're going to
run what's a public what is publicly
declared I'm running for you know House
Representatives as a grading candidate
I mean they're going to have to do
something even if you might have been
that once you publicly declare
even if you just make an announcement
that announcement triggers a range of
legal responsibilities even though you
haven't formally filed yet
and so the day for instance the
candidates show up at Secretary of
State's office with their petitions
saying the presidential preference
primary
um
you know it is often quite a while after
they've already announced their campaign
and are maybe considered candidates
under the loft
but I'm aware of instances where an
individual is proposed
for an office
and had no involvement in that
uh such candidates can have no
involvement
in such efforts and people have a right
to write in whoever they wish on a
ballot
and other people have
a right guarantee by the First Amendment
to
say positive things about other people
in connection with that so I'm just I'm
just saying that this sentence has
written does not seem to apply to
write-in candidates or those campaigning
for such
do we need to change it I don't I'm not
convinced we do
well this bookmark it is an interesting
phrase person publicly declared as such
and if we discover in future research
that it has caused issues right or
confusions maybe we'll have to come back
to it is that fair yes number three
political committee means any
organization of two or more persons that
promotes the success or defeat of a
candidate or candidates
or measure or measures
including the political Committee of a
three so oh so so this has sub this has
three three definitions so this is a b c
d e a b c d
yeah okay so that's a 3A 3B if that's
permitted to go ahead any segregated
fund established by any organization the
purpose of which is to promote the
success or defeat
of a candidate or candidates or measure
measures
C any organization that has as its major
purpose to promote the success or defeat
of a candidate or candidates or measure
or measures and whose receipts or
expenditures
total twenty five hundred dollars or
more in a calendar year for that purpose
so I guess that would not be redundant
because section A said two or more
persons so section c could include one
person
that has also spent money I want to
Circle back to a okay
you know and and I have trouble
accepting that an organization to would
apply to one person
right so if it has to be two people then
then C is covered by a because any group
of two people or more regardless of
whether they've raised or spent any
money counts as a political committee
any group of two people more that
promotes the success or defeat of a
candidate or candidates measure measure
so two people in my living room we call
ourselves the lime Road you know gin
drinkers Club but if we're acting to
promote a measure you don't even have to
do that if uh well going back to a it if
if a husband and a wife don't like
something
yeah
so anyway we should continue with the
full definition but I think that's there
is actually an opportunity to tweak
there or at least streamline and
definitely one is covered by the other
no doubt any organization number d
letter d that does not have as its major
purpose that that does not have its
major purpose to promote the success or
defeat of a candidate or candidates or
measure or measures but that makes
expenditures that total five thousand
dollars a year or more
in a calendar year that's that's
extremely broad that's technically every
company in the state of New Hampshire
yeah technically yeah well it's my
household too technically yes actually
yeah actually that's not even
technically that is yeah every five
thousand dollars or more I mean that's
um any segregate so that's just there
there's a little weirdness here in in
the definitions
any segregated fund that's voluntarily
registered with Secretary of State for
the purpose of reporting its receipts
and expenditures under this chapter or
any organization that voluntarily
registers Secretary of State without
regard
to whether such segregated fund or
organization meets the receiver or
expenditure thresholds described in this
paragraph that covers your tea party
online
if it's registered with the with the
Secretary of State for reporting
receipts and expenditures
next paragraph discusses what
constitutes an organization which
answers the question I was just having
sort of well we'll read it it sort of
answers it
right
or any organization that registers the
secretary of state with that regard to
whether such segregated fund
organization meets the cedar expenditure
thresholds as used in this paragraph
quote organization includes but it's not
entities formed under semicolon entities
formed under state law except those
entities qualified under Section 501c3
for the U.S Internal Revenue code of
1986 semicolon
committees formed by a candidate
exploratory campaign or political party
semicolon
and any other Association of natural
persons or entities formed under state
law that's not registered as a business
entity
so my my favorite part is is
includes but is not limited to
so here's the definition but hey this
am I reading that wrong well it includes
the way I was taught includes but not
limited to is redundant because includes
means
here are some examples of what it
includes not not all of them not all of
them so
I see what you're saying some people
don't necessarily agree with that and
I've noticed in the statute sometimes it
says includes and sometimes it says
includes but not limited to so but
either way it's yeah either way it's
expansive because
I guess the only thing that really
disqualifies is
it's like we're giving these as specific
examples but there might be more out
that are not registered as a business
entity so they they excluded business
entities
but any group it still goes back to any
I still take issue with a which is any
organization of two or more people
that promotes the excess or defeat of a
candidate I mean that is that is
then C just requires them to spend money
so correct in other words a will catch
them if they don't spend money and c
will catch them if they spend money
I think that I think that's the
difference that's the difference but I I
take issue with the political committee
being an organization of two or more
people
I mean if if my wife and I say we like
Alderman X
in this race
well we have now there's two of us
right have now promoted the success or
defeat of a candidate
political committee
but it's not one or more natural persons
yeah you have
that's I mean it's a literal reading
right right yeah you know because we
haven't we haven't assumed a name right
so it it needs to be I think it needs to
be tightened up
so it's under that each of us sitting
here right now in this room is a
political committee then
well I mean I've just expressed my
dismaya his hating of puppies and
kittens assumes someone will join me in
that and that will be a political
committee
but
I'm such a puppy lover that's not what
so
um I mean you could even put in there's
two more people that assume a name right
or something you know something that
obstificates
who's behind it
right because if my wife and I promote
if I say you know Ross and Sammy Barry
endorse blah blah blah for Alderman I
haven't I haven't actually formed a
political committee and it seems like
spending is really what we're correct
what's it has to be that plus a plus c
you could combine the two
right an organization two or more people
I I would I would I would I mean could
you just do with array of a entirely
right
I I don't know if you can that's not a
like we need to that's a that is an
actual question could you actually do
away with a entirely
you know why did they feel it was
necessary to do one as an organization
without spending money in one with with
spending money and you know why why is
it there was there some incident I can
send that off to the our researcher yeah
our our researcher I'll send that off to
I think everyone's these paragraphs
specifically for some reason well 100
yeah 100 but it's like all things you
know you put it's it's even you
the question is did something that they
add to it actually end up encapsulating
stuff in front of it you know
um yeah because yeah because they don't
always do it as a whole correct so we
definitely want to look at
why do I get the feeling that some poor
that the research is going to have to go
get a red book somewhere God God bless
them
so we'll figure out why that is and
we'll Circle back to it not to belabor
would you like me to read since you've
been reading so well by the way it is
truly very melodic uh how appropriate
section four political party or party
means any political organization or a
number of persons which can nominate
candidates in any manner prescribed by
law and has done so for the current
election
the definition of the word party
contained in RSA 65211 shall not apply
to this chapter so a quick uh are you
gonna go roll over to 65211 for us
probably with and has done so for the
that's weird
right I think that's what's making well
I think that's what's making them comply
with this section so if they did it for
past selections do they still have to
come would they have to comply for this
yeah
yeah I would like to say yeah or the
current or previous or previous two or
three elections or something
because you do have the libertarian
party of New Hampshire right they are an
organization right yeah right they did
not nominate I mean I guess they did
nominate a can in the last election but
they may not nominate Congress we also
by the way don't know the Republicans or
the Democrats would technically nominate
I mean it's a it's a fantasy world that
they wouldn't but it's in theory it's
possible
um
so hardy shall mean 650 to 11. any
political organization which at the
preceding state general election
received at least four percent the total
number of votes cast for any one of the
following
Governor or offices of United States
senators
and then the definition of the word
party containers they shall not apply to
this chapter is the more expansive
definition so this is a more expansive
definition for campaign Finance purposes
which is probably good but I think yeah
I mean I would read it as this meaning
I mean we might make it a little more
clear than saying this but it's the the
election that they are now spending
money on and participating in yeah what
I love here is in any manner prescribed
by law except for we actually Define it
in the law right
okay
I don't know how you read that like okay
I just want to make sure we're on the
same page any manner prescribed by law
except for where we actually say what it
is okay
exactly actually I have a question but
would uh somebody Define for me I've
read this many times with the definition
of a natural person
yeah okay an individual human being
would include
any legal entity so it would include a
corporation a partnership an LLC so
person but a natural person is
an individual human
thank you
um so uh
an organization is defined
can be defined is defined in this
uh
party of
664.2 is defined as
by as little as one natural person
but a political committee
to find in Roman numeral three
a requires two or more people
well there's multiple ways to become a
political committee
yes
Roman numeral three a and 664. two or
more people that's one of the ways and I
I take it we're coming back to it but I
take issue with it that's one of the
ways to form a political committee
another way is to be a singular person
who spends who hits the threshold right
so if like yeah if I you know if I could
register as a political committee click
and spend three thousand dollars
which should be different from your
candidates committee
yeah
that was one of the things we did get
rid of thank God
because
the famous Sweeney Sweeney Alexander
Berry some call it the Barry Sweeney
so they put Alexander last even though
um are we good with four
yeah I think it's just it has done so
for the current election is a little bit
grammatically awkward but it sort of
makes the point that they're doing it
now
yeah am I up again
yeah political Committee of a political
party means a state county regional City
ward or town Committee of a political
party a regional committee shall be
composed only of members who are
residents of towns or cities that form a
contiguous land area and shall have been
created and approved by the state
Committee of the political party to
establish Regional committees a party
shall amend its bylaws to authorize them
in principle a copy of the bylaw or
authorization and evidence of the
approval for each Regional committee by
the state committee shall be filed by
the political party with the Secretary
of State before the first Wednesday in
not to my knowledge
it was done in Rockingham County we were
on a teacher you want to take shipping
okay
I I am the the chairman of a regional
political committee
and I've never been informed by the
state committee that they've done so I
why does this section
um detail the regional committee but
leave out City ward Town committees why
is it so detailed about the regional
committee
I mean it's really teachable about the
regional committee
it's really like it got I think they
covered it I'll give them that City ward
and uh Towner to find elsewhere and
understood entities that was trying to
Define Regional
as to differentiate no to differentiate
them from other things but but it
doesn't specify who shall constitute the
members of a city
town or
Ward committee it does for the regional
committees no but but that would be left
why there's a single Regional committees
in terms of who can be an actual member
that's an issue that actually comes up
speaking as the chairman of such a
committee
for some reason there are people from
towns outside are defined three towns
that would like to actually be members
it's an actual thing that comes up
I I would wonder if is it even
appropriate
to tell to tell a I I do take issue when
the state tells political parties how to
organize like I've taken issue with that
since day one I don't like the state
telling private organizations how to
organize
um but this is for campaign Finance
purposes so I guess we need to see
what
where does that fall to my point of it
earlier where does that fall with the
um
I'd like to see an example of a regional
committee I can't
we have Upper Valley Democrats and
uh yeah absolutely contiguous I mean our
our three towns and our bylaws is
approved by the the State political
committee
uh include this restriction on
membership
so
uh all right why is it enshrined in
State Statute is a question I've had for
quite a while because if they spend
money then they are a political
committee and have to abide by the rules
in here
they have to be they have to disclose
there's a disclosure saying that if they
are this then they have to disclose I
don't think it's trying to say who is in
and out of that committee but it does
say that though who can be a member of a
regional committee there's a lot of
requirements for
a political Committee of a political
party once their receipts or
expenditures exceeded I think it's a
thousand now that they we would then
have to file a report but why does it
Define
if someone from a town outside those
three towns
wanted to join us as a full member why
would I have to why do I have to say no
right I mean that that's between that
should be between the political
committee the political party and the
political party organization
it's a
it seems like this section is in one
hand
you know delineating what kind of group
counts as a political committee for
campaign Finance purposes but on the
other hand is also
restricting what kind of group can call
itself a regional Committee of the party
right so that if I were to form a rogue
group Western New Hampshire dams
um the maybe the New Hampshire state
democratic party could use this to say
you're not allowed to you have your your
bylaws haven't been submitted and
approved the I don't know if we're
statute I do know it is
at least past president from the
Secretary of State's office that the
term the various terms Republican
Democrat and libertarian are the
respective property of those recognized
parties
um yeah so like I I I could not go form
Democrats against Muirhead
um as much as I would like to
um
you could not form Republicans against
Barry I'm not here next week you'll know
why
well we'll have a theory anyway
and the Democrats were against you
why would you want to miss such an
interesting discussion
it's just an easy it's an easy
intellectual exercise I mean that so
anyways going back to the original
underlying premise
the parties own the term
I'm trying to flip through here I don't
see where Regional Town City ward
or County committee are mentioned again
why the re why the regional
I mean I I would do anything other than
okay all right maybe we can we can each
I think right and I think we can each
ask well I mean I wonder if there's a
history each of us ask our party
our parties just do they have any
history about why this might be here
yeah because she may not know it may not
be anywhere you know it definitely seems
uh political advertising means any
communication including buttons or
printed materials attached to Motor
Vehicles which expressly or implicitly
Advocates the success or defeat of any
agree right
what's his name I guess there's any
communication it's any communication
expressly
so why don't why doesn't say public
advertisement
means any communication was just get rid
of the including print like why is that
yeah it should say but not limited to to
go back up to the other one
as long as we're consistent yeah I mean
I think we just need to be concerned can
we just delete the part about it's funny
like why would you know why wouldn't it
be buttons or rubber stickers
well it should be
but maybe maybe why those are in there
is because people don't get paid so I
have to pay the newspaper to run an ad
or pay a radio station I'm not paying
people to wear my butt
no but you're Distributing the button
right
if we don't if we don't need to I don't
know it just seems it just seems weird
that that's how do you attach a button
to a motor vehicle anyway that's it well
it might might be helpful to keep
reading through the statute yeah there
is communication next and see and see
how these terms are used yeah because we
are going in alphabetical no I guess
we're not even going alphabetical order
um communication shall include but not
be limited to
there's you're not include but not
limited to it's not even included but
not limited
it's not even anyways uh publication in
any newspaper or other periodical or any
internet site or on any internet site
broadcasting on radio television or any
other public address system
by telephone or facsimile
placement on any Billboards outdoor
facilities Windows window displays
posters cards pamphlets leaflets flyers
well I have seen it I don't like it but
in some documents you can put in
including means and then you say that it
means everything you know not just
what's listed and that way you don't
have to keep coming through here and say
including but not limited to so then we
can it'll it'll cover everything in 664.
if if we want to do that
yeah I'm not sure that's our biggest
problem but it's something that we could
do to clean it up
the nice part is transmission by
telephone includes text messages so
you're all set right
there you go yep
um
just I don't think does anything need to
be added
I don't think I'm missing because they
have on any internet site so that covers
basically all forms of digital
means
um
I I guess if you wanted to get really
into the weeds which I don't even think
I don't know if it's necessary but if
you wanted to you could
you know there are placements on apps
that get used
um
and I do know a thing that is happening
more and more is
um
so you have these services that don't
allow Express political advertisings
right so like Tick Tock does not allow
for Express political advertisements
conversely I can go and hire an
influencer and push my message
um and that influencer wouldn't have to
say
you know and and so and so campaign is
this being paid for by so-and-so
campaign they have to be disclosed in
the campaign Finance reports
but it looks like the point of I know
we're gonna get to it but the point of
the disclosures on Communications
um
wouldn't
would be to include that
um you could make an argument is that is
that any public address system
um but I might I might like to come back
to that and explore that more of
paying people a paid spokesman saying
something political I mean that's
effectively we're talking about
how do we cover that because that is
that is becoming more prevalent and I
think we're going to see a lot of it in
the next cycle
especially on these mediums that don't
allow Express advertisements yeah I mean
I I have a thought and
a suggestion
I do want to be out of here by noon I
think we should be out of here by noon
two hours at one stretch I think is long
enough and uh I think we should reserve
the last five minutes or so just to re
review uh amongst us action items that
we've accepted and well we think the key
points are we've identified here we
should be able to do that in about five
minutes
uh my thought is that we should all
remember that we can't achieve
perfection
even if we ascribe to a totally
totalitarian ideal where we could
so I suggest we just uh maybe for the
next
15 minutes to accelerate the reading of
the definition so we've at least read
them and kind of have them in our minds
a little bit
excuse me
because I was talking on the big fishes
in general yeah we should focus on the
things that have the biggest impact on
what we're concerned about
in my case balancing privacy and burden
against transparency but well we just
finished reading the the uh definitions
okay
warm your heart I'm sure it will uh
eight contributions shall mean a payment
gift subscription assessment contract
payment for service do dues Advance
forbearance or loan to a Canada
political committee made for the purpose
of influencing the nomination or
election of any candidate contributions
shall include there you go the use of
anything of value but shall not include
the services of volunteers who receive
no pay therefore or the use of personal
Resources by a Canon on behalf of his or
her candidacy contributions may be used
by candidates for expenses incurred by
the candidate for child care
no doubt an issue that has come up as
the chairman of the special committee on
child care I'm very excited to see that
yeah
just added in 19 or 19 because it was
not clear and there were some folks who
were paying using campaign contributions
to take care of their kids while they
campaign campaign but it wasn't clear
and a lot of people questioned it so it
was put in specifically seems perfectly
reasonable expenditure shall mean the
disbursement of money of or thing of
value or the making of Legally binding
commitment to make such a disbursement
in the future or the transfer funds by a
political committee to another political
committee or to a candidate for the
purpose of promoting the success or
defeat of a candidate or candidates or
measures or measures expenditures
includes disbursements constituting
independent expendures as defined by
paragraph
11 and expenses incurred by a candidate
for child care it does not include a the
Kansas filing fee for his or her
expenses for personal travel or
substances of substance
B activity designed to encourage
individuals to register to vote or to
vote if the activity of communication
does not mention a clearly identified
candidate
sorry I'm putting a star next to that
because that needs to be
tightened up uh any communication by any
membership organization or Corporation
to its members or stockholders if the
primary purpose of that membership
organizational Corporation is not for
the purpose of promoting the success or
defeat of a candidate or candidate and
any communication by a political
Committee Member that is not made for
the purpose of promoting the success or
defeat of a candidate or candidates or
measures or measure
measure shall mean any Constitutional
Amendment or question which is submitted
or intended to be submitted to a popular
vote at an election
11. independent expenditures means
expenditures May that pay for the
development and distribution of a
communication that expressly Advocates
the election or defeat or clear
identified candidate or candidates for
the success or defeat of a measure of
measures which are made without
cooperation or consultation with any
candidate or any authorized committee or
agent or of such candidate and which are
not made in constant with or at the
request or suggestion of any candidate
or any authorized committee or agent of
such candidate can we at least
acknowledge it's a huge run on sentence
yes and I would like to go back it seems
like almost every year maybe not this
year we got a definition about adding
things into expenditure and trying to do
some specific things that people had
used
um money for but it was not clear
whether or not in some people's minds
whether that was truly an expenditure
um I just highlight that because it
seems to come up often we often see a
bill that way I still think this is
pretty comprehensive and probably
doesn't need it but I just bring that up
so that we might want to look at it in
between our next meeting because I it
um I think something we could probably
agree on is I don't think there should
be I think expenditures and I know
there's going to be an exemption coming
up about like social events or something
I think any expenditure that a candidate
makes out of their campaign or pack
makes out of their campaign should be
accounted for that's just my personal
should be accounted for no matter what
it is it should be kind of there should
be no
if
if they want to spend it on on their
lobster bake that's their business but
we should disclose all that stuff that's
just my opinion but anyways uh should I
continue
after the uh full name means an
individual's full first name middle name
or initial if any and full legal last
name making the identity of the
contributor a parent by unambiguous
reference
middle names
no I was not even aware you had to get
middle names plural middle names it
should be
there you go for some of us
middle name or initial or initial or
names so technically we're supposed to
be collecting middle initial for every
contributor where possible
technically
yes okay yeah probably look at that
um post office we're going to define a
post office address means individuals
principal place of residence and shall
not include a street or post-op P.O box
if any Street city state or zip code
post office address shall not mean an
individual's business address be an
individual's home address and rental
property address when the home and
rental property is owned but not
occupied by the contributor and c and
got
it anyway
they were consistent in that section
though
oh they you do it they just throw a
period in there and they're like yeah
and I think I heard when Ross read it I
think he read uh put in a knot that
doesn't belong there oh uh
means an individual's principal place of
residence and shall include a street and
post office box if any I think you
read the word not there by mistake yes
that's right yep
uh occupation means an individual's
official job title resulting from
employment at or ownership of an agency
organization or other entity
principal place of business means the
primary organization or employer from
which an individual derives his or her
principal income and shall include the
employer's official name and the
16. business organization means in any
Enterprise whether Corporation
partnership limited liability company
proprietorship Association business
trust real estate trust work other form
of organization organized for gain or
profit and includes any Enterprise which
is expressly made exempt
um expressly made exempt from income
taxation under the United States
Internal Revenue code of 1980s 1986. it
does not include a political committee
as defined by RSA 6642 Section 3 or the
political Committee of a political party
is defined by 664.2 section 5.
push polling push pulling means calling
voters on behalf of in support of or in
opposition to any candidate for the for
for public office by telephone and
asking questions relative to opposing
candidates for public office which state
implied or convey information about the
candidates character status or political
stance or record and conducting such
calling in a manner which is likely to
be construed by the voter to be a survey
or a poll to gather statistical data
from entities or organizations which are
acting independent of any particular
political party candidate or interest
group as part of a series of like
telephone calls that consist of more
than 2 000 connected calls that last
more than two minutes in presidential
gubernatorial United States senatorial
or United States Congressional elections
or conducting such calling as a part of
a series of like telephone calls that
consist of more than 500 connected calls
that last more than two minutes in
executive council state senate City Town
School District or Village District
elections or conducting such calling as
a part of a series of like telephone
calls that consists of more than two
unconnected calls that last less than
two minutes in state representative
elections and conducting such calling
for purposes other than bona fide survey
for refining yes because it's out of
date that's yeah that is just a disaster
and I googled the math main Commission
on governmental ethics definitions it's
a more they're more easier ways to do
these definitions out there
it's interesting to me that you can make
a uh call that's three minutes
and it does this doesn't apply correct
yep
uh button opinion research means the
collection analysis of data regarding
opinions needs awareness knowledge views
experiences or behaviors of a population
through the development administration
of surveys interviews focus group pulse
observation or other research
methodologies in which no sales
promotional or marketing efforts are
involved and through which there is no
attempt to influence a participant's
attitudes or behavior bona fide survey
and other independent research includes
message testing which is the study for
the research purpose of how randomly
selected individuals react to positive
oh or negative information of a
candidate elected public official or
ballot question receipts receipts shall
mean the receipt of money or thing of
value of the receipt of illegally
binding commitment to receive money over
thing of value in the future for the
purpose of promoting the success or
defeat of a candidate or candidate of or
measure or measures receipts shall not
include amounts received by a political
Committee in commercial transactions in
the ordinary course of any trade or
business conducted by the political
committee or in the form of invest
investments in the political committee
or the amounts received by the political
committee from pairs who at the time of
payment prohibited in writing the use of
the payment as an expenditure
we have three more
segregated fund shall mean a segregated
account of money that consists of funds
with that that were paid directly to
such account by persons other than the
covered political committee that
controls the account from which only
expenditures defined in paragraph 9 are
made
21 clue identified candidate means the
name of the candidate involved appears a
photograph or drawing of the candidate
appears or the identity of the candidate
is otherwise apparent and last but not
least 22 political advocacy
organizations I mean Indian team that
spends five thousand dollars more to
calendar year to pay for a communication
that is functionally equivalent to
express advocacy because when taken as a
whole such communication is likely to be
interpreted by a reasonable person only
as advocating the election or defeat of
the clear identified candidate or
candidates or the success of it or
defeat of a measurement measures taking
into account whether the communication
involved mentions a candidacy or a
political party or takes a position on a
candidates characters qualifications for
excellent
so
all right okay there is an action item I
could suggest that maybe individuals
collect
a list form you know individuals want to
make changes to this section bring a
list of suggested changes to the next
meeting and distribute it
I agree with that
um I do I will send off to our
researcher
um
Regional committees
and
um section three
um 6642 section three number eight uh
letter A
about why
um
the why the definition exists
so that's those are the two things I'm
doing and apparently what professor
are you Professor or Dr mirin
um Professor I feel like if you can't
help someone who's having a heart attack
oh wow you shouldn't be called doctor
that's right that's that's very high in
my interview well I would say it's it's
context dependent if if someone needs
urgent help in resolving a question of
political Theory I think you could then
use the title
so
anyway Ross would you repeat those two
please uh I'm doing
664.2 Section 3 definition a
as a research question and
um same 6642 section
uh Section 5 as to Regional committees
why are we doing that sort of stuff
okay
is anyone are you Contracting the agent
contract the Democratic party and ask
them about why that last sentence and
defining political committee is if they
have any history about that because I
know you're going to ask yeah a
researcher but I'm going to ask I'll ask
I had I had an action item about
contacting the Secretary of State's
big lift big lift yeah big lift there
thanks Ian Fearless leadership right
there
okay
and
all right well it's it's uh six minutes
to 12 according to the car according to
the clock on the wall
is there anything else anyone would like
to discuss
are we meeting is it next two weeks
right two weeks on the ninth and the
16th
okay okay
with this extra six minutes today
based on your comments over the last
months I'm sure you can find something
you can start your drive home sooner all
right then I'm going to adjourn this
meeting
at 11 55. meetings adjourned
I'm going to use very good I'm gonna get
the undercarriage wash I will uh see you